guys at a periodical launch little
competition to find the integer sequence
2013 a little bit fun not a serious
thing but basically they've looked at
the online encyclopedia of integer
sequences and they've basically run a
competition to see which one is the best
then it's based on various categories
like aesthetics novelty explicable 'ti
completeness these sorts of things but
just a bit of fun but before we'd we'd
go through these sequences and I'm not
going to tell you which one I like best
and so I'll leave that to the end I can
do my best poker face to try and keep it
a secret so the first one in the
sequence is it's to do with the decimal
expansion of a particular constant okay
so the decimal expansion of insurance
constant is the following two point six
eight five four okay so that doesn't
look very exciting right just by looking
at it key choice on since is it is a
remarkable number actually basically if
you take any number or almost all
numbers to be more precise almost all
numbers and you work out the continued
fraction expansion of that guy so for
example we just take a general number X
and we can know that we can write this
is with a naught plus 1 over a 1 plus 1
over a 2 plus and so on you keep going
on like this right this is called these
a nor a 1 it on all those a call the
continued fraction expansion well let's
say I take the product of all these aids
I take a 1 times a to forget annual at
times a 3 and so on to am and I take the
geometric mean so I just take an nth
power of that and I see what that gives
me as I sent as I go to infinity so as n
goes to infinity it goes to kitchens
constant and this is true of almost any
number that's amazing I think that's an
amazing fact it's almost like now
obviously you're going to immediately
tell me well it's not true of a lot of
numbers that you know about it's not
true of 1/2 for example because the
continued fraction expansion of 1/2 is
not clearly interested any rational
number it you can get basically any
number out doing this process but most
numbers do that's the amazing thing
almost all numbers know
channel numbers will do it but most
numbers do PI for example is thought so
when you take the expansion in this guy
this calculate this number for pi you're
expected to get insurance constant in
fact hint to improve that almost all
numbers do it by that it means all
numbers except for a sort of potentially
an infinitesimally small set and the
great thing about this is is that K not
itself which seems to know about almost
all numbers also knows about itself
because it's thought like this hasn't
been proven that K naught when you do
this expansion for it averages to accept
then take this average it recovers
itself so if you like it's a little bit
if there was a number that had was if
God had it on there right it would be
this number because it knows about
almost all other numbers and itself it's
kind of like beautifully self-contained
okay so next one in the sequence this is
the V Furyk primes and they're basically
there's only two numbers in this
sequence that we know of 1093 and 3511
so what what are these guys the V Furyk
Prime's are any prime number P such that
P squared divides two to the P minus one
minus one and it's true of these two
numbers we don't know if it's true of
any other numbers in fact I was
interested if there were any higher ones
than this and as you found a paper which
says that well they've done a search for
V for it Prime's all the way up to six
point seven times ten to the fifteen and
they haven't found any more so you've
got these two low guys and then nothing
all the way up to that so the next one
the sequence is going to be some huge
number if indeed it exists well the
reason V for it was interested in them
is they seem to have something to do
with Fermat's Last Theorem he was trying
to prove Fermat's Last Theorem the
reason is that fee for it proved the
following result you take X to the P
plus y to the P 4 z to the P equals 0 x
y&z are integers and you say that P does
not divide XYZ then you can prove what
this is what v4 it did that P has to be
one of these V fruit primes ok so next
up is Gollum sequence so this is Gollum
sequence Lord of the Rings yeah well
actually this guy's got an amazing name
Solomon
that's just the coolest name in the
world right so he's actually quite an
interesting guy he's a mathematician
invented pentominoes which is just a
mathematical game but it was the
forerunner of tetris actually so Solomon
Golomb was the guy who potentially
invented tetris what is his sequence his
sequences is the following 1 2 2 3 3 4 4
4 5 5 5 and so on and what does this
sequence tells well this sequence kind
of knows about itself because this sort
of nth position in this sequence tells
you how many times the number n appears
in the sequence I start with the first
position list then the question is how
many times does 1 appear in the sequence
well the answer is it only appears once
it can only appear once I couldn't put a
2 here that would make sense then I go
to the next point now I'm asking how
many times is the number to appear in
the sequence well you can see that it is
2 it had to be 2 it couldn't be 1
because then one would have appeared
twice and I've had to put 2 here you see
so it kind of makes sense that it has to
be 2 so then I go to the third point in
the sequence which is this position here
okay now the question I have to ask is
how many times does 3 appear in the
sequence but I've already said that 2
had to appear twice so I better put 2
there so the number of times that 3 has
to appear in the sequence has to be 2
and so there they are the next point in
the sequence and you keep going you keep
going in this manner this position the
question is how many times does 4 appear
in the sequence well here you are
it appears three times and so on and so
on
and you build the sequence of this way
it kind of knows about itself it's sort
of it's almost like it it doesn't you
know maybe it's have a bit of therapy or
something it really knows it's it's in
obeying sort of thing and now there is a
little another feature of this sequence
is that as you get to very very large
numbers where does this sequence a get
go to well it goes to the following the
ant put position of this sequence will
tend towards Phi 2 minus F Phi and Phi
minus 1 now what is this ok this is n
what's this this verify thing I've
written down this Greek letter
this is the golden ratio just appears
everywhere okay so the next one are the
largest meted roams so what why is this
well a meta drone is a number which
appears in stricter zones where the
numbers appear in strict descending
order let me write down the sequence
first zero one five twenty seven one
nine four one eight six five and so on
it's the largest method row so the
largest number that you can write where
all the numbers in strict descending
order Bay set okay so the first position
this is zero base one okay first
position so it's got to be something
this base one okay and it's a large
number we can write that strict
descending order of X 1 is zero okay so
this is zero base one this guy is next
one one what is that well that is one
base two okay so it's the large number
we could have written but they're all
this strict descending order
base two because we're in the second
position those two aren't that exciting
it's a little bit more interesting when
you get to the next number so we know
what this number should be what if it's
five well what's that that is one to
base three
okay well of course it is because one to
base three is basically 3 plus T ok next
one keep going 27 this is one two three
base 4
okay which is 4 squared plus 2 times 4
plus 3 which is 27 okay and you keep
going like this and this is how the
sequence of Ages while the next on the
sequence would be 1 2 3 4 base 5 okay
and the next would be 1 2 3 4 5 basics
exactly exactly and so on I think that
one's a bit deliver but it doesn't
doesn't push my buttons and footage and
think about secrets so I haven't figured
out what was your favorite yeah I think
it's not out what I'll give you a clue
on that ok ok so moving swiftly on it is
all the sevens I think this is your
favorite isn't it Brady I have to admit
I don't know why it's so much about it
yet but it appeals to me ok so what is
all the seventh well this does what it
says on the tin it's 7 7 7 7
seven and so this is just a nonsense II
think it's just an answer sequence fit
you know it's a vehicle and there is
some you can relate it's some massive
you if you try hard enough I'm not sure
that's my favorite anymore it's even
gone up and actually there was some
equation for that but okay so we now
consider the last of the sequences
that's that's been nominated and these
are the wild numbers rule that sounds
exciting
okay so what are the wild numbers well
they are 1167 - there's supposed to be
an infinite number below are these what
is this sequence well it's actually
completely made up secrets that come out
of fiction there is a guy called air
Philibert shota I hope I've pronounced
that properly who wrote a novel about a
mathematician and air and he solved a
problem called the wild number problems
so what was the wild number problem the
idea was that you would take any whole
number you would apply some water
described as simple operations to that
okay that would turn that number into
fractions and then you would keep
applying these operations until you get
back to a whole number again the claim
is that there those numbers that you end
up with are the wild numbers and of all
the examples that were supposedly known
these were the only numbers that were
popping up so the question would be are
all you know are there an infinite
number of wild numbers are there numbers
that aren't wild numbers well in the
book apparently three is a tame number
it can never it's been proven that this
can never be reached and what the guy in
the story does is he and his the idea is
that he will he proves he's a very
exposed to be a mediocre mathematician
who's disillusioned with his career but
he proves the end that there are an
infinite number of wild numbers which is
switches there being this long-standing
problem there's a nice little a account
of only on the archive actually that we
use by the author of the Matz behind it
and the ideas behind it but he's written
a novel but this is a paper about the
novel so this is what he's done so he
says something quite interesting in it
in that the idea was that would be this
mediocre mathematician it was then ended
up sort of solving Fermat's Last Theorem
which of course at a time hadn't been
solve of course now it has by by Andrew
Wiles but at the time it happened and so
the idea was this mediocre mathematician
it comes up
the proof of Fermat's Last Theorem and
ok-hee so you've sort of pitched this
idea to a mathematician friend of his
and his mathematician friend just sort
of shot it down straight away he said
there's no way a mediocre mathematician
would be able to actually come up with a
solver a long-standing proof like that
it would always be somebody who's an
established genius now obviously that's
true in Andrew Wiles this case that you
know a genius did ultimately find a
proof Fermat's Last Theorem book
recently of course we did a video about
you know this prime number theorem the
twin prime conjecture x' and that was
solved by what was essentially you know
not a star of mathematics so maybe maybe
the the the author's friend was a little
bit unfair there but anyway gave the
author license to so then go away and
invent these wild numbers in there so he
made up wild numbers so instead of using
firm s though exactly exactly it was so
fulfilling prophecy that wasn't it if
you do solve one of these theorems you
become a genius well I think so yeah
yeah yeah sure sure exactly but I think
the claim was that these people would
have been noticed before because they
would have these these theorems get
built off and you build towards them and
the proof sighs so you've showed me your
six yeah which was your favorite
he's got think it's got the Hitchens
constant right the decimal expansion of
that I mean that number is just blown
away by that number and what it is
conceived it almost all numbers when you
you know take this property to do with
the you know the continued fraction
expansion almost all numbers give you
back this constant that's amazing that's
an amazing fact except the numbers you
and I use almost yesterday but that's
but that's such a tiny fraction that's
it that's a minuscule fraction of all
numbers they're out of it you know it's
if it's a measure zero fraction of it to
the fact so the vast majority of numbers
the vast truly vast majority do give
like this guy Pike is it well that's
what that's what we think so that for me
is it is absolutely incredible and
that's why I like that guy yes I said if
there's a number which you know it has
any kind of divinity to it this one I
think I read somewhere that if we if
we're going to sort of send out some
information to aliens we
should send out and it's going to be
numeric we should tell them about this
constant so I do like that number but I
do have a sequence of personal seeing as
that that I like more that I'd like to
show you Brady
I think so actually I know what this is
okay well let me let me write it down I
said you see he can guess it ready I
guess are it on the media there okay so